there's tons of other businesses that
you can absolutely demolish who are
making lots of money just by doing the
basics and if you execute on that for 10
years your business Grows by default
because your competitors won't do that
growing businesses is hard because it's
different than people expect it to be
the singularity of focus is so important
we get presented opportunities every
single day that could distract us and
the thing is the bigger you get the
bigger the opportunities that get
presented to you so the harder it is to
say no I want to tell a quick story
about the woman in the red dress and I'm
going to relate it to business in The
Matrix one of my favorite movies there's
the woman in the red dress and so it's
one of the training programs that
Morpheus takes Neo on uh the main
character to teach him one simple lesson
and so they're walking through a crowd
it's normal New York lots of people
everyone looks different and then
there's this woman in this red dress and
Neo's head turns and morphis is still
talking to him trying to teach him a
lesson right and then he looks back and
more if he's like re-listing and he was
like what he's like were you looking at
the one in the red dress and he says
look again he looks back at the woman
and it's agent Smith pointing his gun to
his head the thing is is I see
distractions and New Opportunities shiny
object as the woman in the red dress and
at every level of business the woman in
the red dress becomes more and more
attractive because at first you have to
say no to thousand opportunities then
ten thousand then a hundred thousand and
you have to learn how to say no again at
every level because I thought that once
I learned how to say no to the one in
the red dress I'd be done forever but
that's not true she comes back every
level she just gets hotter and hotter
and hotter I used to think that like
Innovation was everything and I think
Innovation is important a very very
small degree but the vast majority of
the business success is actually doing
all the stuff that you know you should
be doing but you aren't A friend of mine
has a wife who's really popular and they
have literally 60 businesses he has an
Excel sheet to keep track of all the
businesses he has and I think they make
about total between everything maybe
eight figures a year and to some people
like oh that's amazing but hear me out
so we're having this long conversation
and I just said you know if there were a
magic wand and you could snap your
fingers and eliminate all businesses but
one how easy do you think it'd be to
grow that business he was like oh my God
it would be so easy to grow that to like
30 or 50 million I was like then why
don't you do that and he said that that
question has messed with him for an
entire year and he has since that
conversation shut down business after
business after best business after
business so that he could focus on the
one that he thought was the biggest
opportunity Mark Zuckerberg didn't have
side hustles if you do one thing and you
do it right you do it all the way you
can get as big as you want you can have
a long way business that cover the
entire United States you could do that
you could have a Cosmetics business that
covers the entire United States you
could have whatever type of business you
want that covers everyone if you waited
for a long enough for your time and
didn't get distracted it's one of my
favorite poses by Neil Strauss he said
success comes down to doing the obvious
thing for an uncommonly long period of
time without convincing yourself you're
smarter than you are it's the details
that pay the dividends the depth and the
Nuance of understanding how to do
something and so for example right now
obviously lots of opportunities that we
have I still don't feel like we're doing
the basics if we're not on every
platform why are we thinking about
starting a new business if we're not
hardcore email marketing regularly and
providing value why are we going to
start another business if we're not even
building the SEO out on our site why are
we doing something else if we haven't
completely built out the sales training
for our sales team to keep their
execution High why are we thinking about
doing other things and so so many
entrepreneurs that I see who are we're
talking about how they want to grow
their business and do this next new
thing or this exciting add-on aren't
even doing the basics and the thing and
I've said this before but being Advanced
means that you never don't do the basics
and if you're like well Alex that's
going to take so much time for me to do
each of those things welcome to building
a big business because big businesses do
the same things little businesses do but
they do them better and they fill the
holes in the bucket and so if you were
to think about a business as a bucket
and you've got water pulling in the top
which is the traffic or the eyeballs or
whatever and then the bucket is what
you're keeping right so the first thing
that you're going to do if you want to
grow the amount of water you have in the
bucket is you don't have multiple
buckets what you're going to do is
probably fix the holes in the bucket you
got number one fix the bucket number two
once you fix the bucket increase the
flow to the bucket once you've done that
and you've completely maximized that
then you add new flows but most people
have never done that and so the moniker
that I remember about this is better
more new and so whenever I'm thinking
about our business or our businesses in
the portfolio I think have we maxed out
better yet if we we have not maxed
better yet there's no point in incurring
the risk of more renew because more is
riskier than better better is the lowest
risk opportunity that everyone has do
what you're currently doing do it better
follow it faster follow up more make
better copy make better creative
optimize your site hire better people
train them better have better Management
Systems better incentive systems but
you're like but Alex that sounds so
boring welcome to Growing big [ __ ] it's
how you do it you literally fill all the
holes in the bucket that you know you
should be doing but aren't if you were
to make a list of the top 25 things that
you could do in your business that you
are not doing the obvious things that
you know would make you more money if I
emailed more admit more if I did more
reach out to make more money if I made
more content I make more money if I
train my sales team or if I did more
call reviews I'd make more money if I
did reorganize our customer onboarding
process if I created a better Cadence or
training for our customer support team
or customer success team we need to make
more money put out every single one of
the obvious bullets that you had that
you know would grow your business
instead of doing the new thing do those
first and once you finish that list what
you will see happen and this is why it's
spiritually difficult as an Entre
because we stopped doing the old thing
we started the new thing and we got
reinforcing that behavior and so we
learned the wrong lesson we learned that
when we start new things good things
happen and so we think we should start
new things this is where it's difficult
and we have to learn at each level you
started the new thing and you got
rewarded but now if you start another
thing you will get punished and some
people never unlearn that first lesson
and so you have to switch from new to
better because the Innovation already
happened when you got the product Market
fit as soon as people started buying the
thing you're selling that's when the new
needs to end for a while because now you
just need to do better and more so you
fill the holes in the bucket with all
the better and then you do more then you
go from one piece of content a day to
five pieces of content a day from one
sales guy to five sales guys from one
video editor to five video editors it's
about doing more once you fix the first
one and make it better businesses will
grow by default and they will beat their
competition if they do everything their
competition does but better because what
happens is most entrepreneurs will
divert resources from their core thick
think about the two paths boring
entrepreneur number one who finally
finds product Market that people like
the stuff that they're are selling and
then they say I'm not going to do
anything new for the next five years all
I'm going to do is do this better and do
more of it that's all I'm going to do
and then you think about the other guy
who says oh we got some product Market
fit fantastic now I'm gonna sell
something else and I get to get my rock
sock get my jollies off over here
thinking about all this new stuff all
this new marketing all this new product
while the other business starts to
wither away a little bit because atrophy
starts happening because the things that
were there when you're overseeing it
aren't happening anymore anyways and not
only that it's never improving and cost
of media goes up cost of talent goes up
and the business is literally getting
worse relative to the market over time
if you're not improving it and so you
got these two entrepreneurs and this guy
is diverting resources that would have
been allocated back to the same bucket
to fill the holes as instead taking some
of that and trying to build another
Bucket over here meanwhile the holes are
getting bigger in the first bucket
because it's getting worse and worse and
worse and so then they find themselves
with five buckets that are all tons of
holes in them they don't have the
bandwidth to actually go to the one
bucket and fix it and that's when I
asked the magic wand question so right
now if you have multiple things going on
how easy would it be to grow your
business if I could wave a magic wand
snap my fingers and everything ended
except for one pretty easy right so why
not stack the chips in your favor the
thing that makes it hard is the
discipline you have to have not the
concept strategy is easy execution is
hard it's the execution risk that is the
much bigger risk for most businesses if
you deliver dry cleaning that is always
clean always and always on time you'll
have an exceptional business the
strategy isn't complicated it's the
execution is where everyone fails but
this is the thing is that the strategy
is the new and exciting thing people
allocate tons of attention tons of time
two new strategies new ideas rather than
making the obvious truth of if I deliver
everyone their clothes on time and they
are always perfectly clean this business
will work one of the things that we do
when we're growing the business after
understanding better more new when we
think about anything that we're growing
is what are the need to believe what do
we need to believe for this to grow we
need to believe that people will always
want things fast do is that something I
want to bet on yes people always want a
good product so that we clean their
clothes perfectly every time do I
believe that that's something that
people want in the future as much they
want to date or more yes people will
always want good service do I believe
that that's something we're on the
future or in the day yes it's one of the
Beautiful Things is that when you enter
a Marketplace something as boring as dry
cleaner boring as Lawn Care boring is
whatever is that oftentimes you're
actually not competing it's the smartest
people in the world because smartest
people in the world are on Silicon
Valley all are trying to make the next
platform but there's tons of other
businesses that you can absolutely
demolish who are making lots of money
just by doing the basics and what makes
them Basics is how hard they are to
understand but what makes you Advanced
is how well you execute them like it's
not hard to conceptualize that you take
10 guys and each guy makes 200 calls a
day it's 2 000 calls a day it's not hard
to conceptualize that how well did you
train them how well did you recruit them
what is their incentive structure do you
listen to calls on a regular basis is
there a leaderboard because you're
thinking yourself when you have that big
list ah we need to do competitions for
the sales thing oh I need to get that
leaderboard set up oh yeah I need to be
doing more call reviews that is the
stuff that grows the business it's not
the big idea people always want leads
promise you you know how to get leads
you know how to get them better you will
make tons of money people always need a
place to live you have better buildings
that are cleaner and things run right
and you treat your residence well you
have successful buildings if you have uh
lawn care where everyone communicates
well and is cost effective and the the
grass always looks great and the hedges
are clean lines at the Cadence that's
perfect for most people you will have a
good business you might be competing
against people who are not who don't
even think that way and so you can
absolutely take their lunch money but
you have to not get fancy so when I was
going through the sale process for two
of our companies Bankers introduced me
to a couple of other CEOs that they had
done deals with because I I wanted to
know what it was like after things like
that like oh we can just connect with
these guys so I talked to one of them
and the conversation changed my life he
was a mercenary CEO so he was a third
time CEO that private Equity buy company
Place him in he'd grow it and then
they'd sell it and he had done that
three times already so super seasoned
guy he was a long island guy really
thick accent he said you know everybody
wants the super fancy trick plays you
know it's like okay hike and then I you
know fix to the left and then we go
right and then it's actually going to be
reverse you know whatever and then and
then we toss it and then what do you
know what happens he uh he catches it
and then fumbles it and the other team
takes it down for a touchdown he's like
no we're doing Simple backyard football
he's like two fat guys in the middle run
to the right consistent yardage he's
like don't be cute and he said that and
it really changed the way I saw business
you don't need to have any fancy play to
be successful you just have to be
willing to get the consistent yardage
people want clean clothes people want
them fast people want good service and
if you execute on that for 10 years and
you fill every hole in the bucket your
business Grows by default because your
competitors won't do that this is where
I say like business is not hard in that
it is not complicated it is hard because
people cannot stay focused on the same
thing for a long period of time it's
also because once people make a certain
amount of money if they only did it for
the income they're trying to find the
next thing that's going to make more
income rather than the mission of the
business because if you believe in the
mission of the business you will be
willing to do it for an extraordinary
long period of time and I can tell you
right now from all the friends that I
have that make shitloads of money
they've all been doing the same thing
for a long period of time so as much as
the world wants to tell you you should
have 17 majors in college and you should
taste everything and I think there's
value to that it will not fight against
the reality Ben Francis started gymshark
when he was whatever 17 and now he's 28
or 29 he's got a billion dollar thing
could he have tasted more stuff sure he
tasted from like 14 to 17 right but then
when he started that he's been doing it
for 10 or 11 years now now he's a
billion dollar thing the work needs
doing and you just need to decide when
you want to start the compounding clock
in your favor which means how long can I
commit to this thing and so I would say
once you've had a little bit of your
entrepreneurial licks as fast as you can
to learn those lessons you have to think
what need to believe is there that I do
not think will change over an extended
time Horizon and then serve that every
day all you do is you look at how to do
better and how to do more of it and it's
going to kill you inside because you
like doing new [ __ ] and that's what was
positively reinforced your entire life
as an entrepreneur in the beginning and
then you have to unlearn that lesson
because that's what it takes to get big
is you do the same thing and you just do
it that much better than everyone else
and that takes time it is arrogant to
believe that you are going to out
compete other people who are fully
focused on one thing when you're split
on five like think about how arrogant it
is to think that and the thing is plenty
of people arrogant so many of you will
still do this but you'll also still be
poor so whatever some dude is he's got a
lawn care business and all he does is
longer all day every day that's all he
does is molons and he believes that
everybody deserves an amazing long
because he's got a story when he's a kid
and that was the only thing that his
parents could do was cut the lawn to
even though they were poor it was like
something that gave them status
neighborhood and he'd remember his dad
crying because somebody give him a
compliment on and he hadn't gotten a
Coughlin forever whatever that reason is
he's driven to make that company and he
got the other guy who's like oh yeah I'm
doing Drop Shipping I'm doing some Lawn
Care stuff and I'm doing some Consulting
gigs on the side for marketing and I'm
you know I'm doing nfts whatever right
he's got all these things going on who
is going to win at lawn care it's
obvious and yet we still live like this
other guy and so my hope is that you
recognize that if that's you stop and
I'm only saying this from a place of
love because I had nine businesses
before Jim launch took off before you
think oh well what I'm gonna do because
I hear this all the time I'm gonna do
them all and see which one takes off
none of them will take off because any
of them could take off if you just focus
on one of them thinking that the outside
Market is somehow gonna make you
successful like you're gonna pick the
right bet when you can force any of them
to be successful right provider you're
not selling newspapers and acquaintance
Amaya from high school and he said hey
I've got a roofing business you know
it's awesome I said oh that's great and
he said oh yeah we also uh do real
estate flipping it was like okay all
right he's like oh and we also do uh
General Contracting okay he's like oh we
do window stuff too that's actually
glass and windows we do that stuff too
because it's like you want to be
vertically integrated for Real Estate I
was like dude you're doing like four
million bucks a year like you're not
vertically integrated you're just
distracted
if you look at the biggest roofing
companies in the world they're billion
dollar companies billion multi-billion
dollar companies you can do one thing to
scale and make all the money you want
and you will only get there with the
scale from the details from the depth
that's how you get these compounding
returns from doing the same thing over
and over again because you get better
about a better at it the other guy who's
got four things he's never gonna get
good at any of them he's just gonna be
barely good enough and he's going to
make barely good enough money if you're
not making money in any of the things is
because you don't understand any of them
well enough because if you can see
anybody in your industry who's doing the
thing that you're doing and making a
hundred times more money than you it's
because they know it better than you so
how quickly you're going to pay down the
ignorance you're going to try and divide
it by four you're gonna try and pay down
the ignorance instead of one of them as
fast as you can so you can start the
compound